what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here
we got mike's today which means this is
serious business
important this is a very professional
video when you
got a microphone set up in front of your
face so listen to us
listen to us as we got to talk about
today is important
information we got two main things to
talk about
first one being zack snyder is possibly
being courted here to direct a
ghostwriter movie for
marvel and the other one is about some
spider-man 3 news possibly some major
character deaths conflicting reports
all around circling that specific
subject so let's kick this off with the
one that will probably be shorter than
the spider-man one so john
what's going on here with zachary
schneider zachary give us
the gists this short version here go
take it away all right well do it
according to keep going
ghost rider has gone back and forth
between hulu
but sources and this is important
sources
close to me to uh uh john specifically
close to john yeah
this is my message they basically say
the ghost rider's destination depends on
how well the blade
reboot performs they go on to say marvel
studios believes that blade should be
the launch pad
of the supernatural team the midnight
sons of which
ghost rider is one of the frequent
members this basically comes on the
heels of reports that kevin feige is
interested in
expanding the sort of horror side of the
mcu perhaps into hulu because we all
know that disney plus
is not the most friendly when it comes
to adult material you know they
have certain means through which they
can basically
link your hulu apparently to disney plus
and maybe be able to kind of bring those
series out that way that's clever so the
question is should zack snyder do this
right that's the question of the day i
could see a yes and no for
very specific reasons on this yes
because
i think zack snyder could do it like
visually
undoubtedly visually he could do it
especially bringing a lot more of those
demonic
hellish landscapes to life i think he
could probably pull off
the best ghost rider action if they
wanted to make it r rated i think it'd
be even that much better if they wanted
to let ghost rider be a lot more i don't
know if they let him go hard r but a
little bit more on the violent side even
if it was like pg-13
borderline rated r you can get away with
a lot of supernatural
you know mumbo jumbo and two i mean
flaming chain
cauterizes wounds so you know there's a
scientific work around and they've
basically said that they haven't
approached zack snyder but he is one of
the names in heavy consideration
i feel like zack snyder's the kind of
director who'd be like yeah sure i could
at least talk about it and see what's
going on here the thing though is
what's very evident with zack snyder is
he works best when he's allowed to do
whatever he really
wants to do and let him be unleashed
and he often makes very long films now
whichever version a ghost rider you go
with
i think he can pull it off if you look
at his for example the the snyder verse
trilogy that he had come out
all those characters have this level of
dealing with feeling lost or having this
issue with self-acceptance
and i feel like that goes hand in hand
with ghost rider as well the human side
of him right but should he do it
i would like to see it done however i'm
like well marvel i think is even more
strict than dc
when it comes to how they want their
films to ultimately be executed and he's
the kind of director that you
you know ghost rider is all about change
and you don't want chains to be
around zack snyder that way he can make
the best film he could possibly make
whenever you gotta trim him down
it doesn't turn out as good so here are
the things that intrigued me about this
is you know what like we saw potentially
that didn't end up panning out with
justice league but there was the talk of
turning that into a miniseries part of
me wonders if
maybe to indulge zack snyder's penchant
for
long-running stories they could do
something like that whereas yeah
some kind of hulu mini-series but one
thing that struck me is that yeah like
marvel is very in control of their
properties however they do seem much
less apt to just like
jump in right in the middle of something
or quarters of the way through something
and change it entirely
so part of me feels like it would be
about getting zack snyder and kevin
feige on the same page
from the get-go and if that can happen
then i don't really have so much concern
and the other thing i thought was
interesting is marvel cinematic universe
kind of has this
you know uh image of being you know fun
and
and it's the kind of go-to reference for
like ah they're injecting fun
into something just like the mcu and
like we saw with justice league they
clearly wanted to take
notes from the mcu with joss whedon's
version and so this is funny to me
because i feel like in a way it almost
seems fitting that they would go
we want to take the universe a little
bit darker zack snyder that's your thing
come over here yeah i can see it working
out i can also see it
very much not working out this will
refer to you guys you guys want to see
sex
what do you want to see leave your
thoughts down below leave the plot leak
so moving on we got some spider-man
information here to talk about so here's
like the
short version of this complicated piece
there's reports coming out there's gonna
be a major character death
maybe a couple in spider-man no way home
spider-man might be hunting down green
goblin with the intent to kill him but
ultimately doesn't which is what sam
raimi's first spider-man movie was
inspired from from the end
godspeed spider-man so we might be
dealing with a similar plot to that one
one report is saying that andrew
garfield might be getting the axe and
this time around
one is saying that it could be aunt may
who's the one who's going to be killed
off
i feel like actually a death happening
in this movie
would be good for the film because you
got
so much going on here already there's so
much
crazy theme park-esque levels
of marvel cinematic greatness on display
i feel like to ground this into
something feeling more
personal for specifically tom holland's
peter parker in this journey a death
could
serve as a strong focal point a strong
personal service that way there's an emo
it's true emotional hook into here
beyond just the nostalgic elements
of all these multiverses crashing
together in this one movie if they were
to kill off
aunt may i don't really know how i'd
feel about that there's been a lot of
debate i think amongst spider-man
fans over the years it's like for the
most part we all like tom holland
but there is that debate that has come
up about how not
really acknowledging the death of uncle
ben or having that be an
impact on the character peter parker
kind of goes against peter parker
to a certain extent and so much of the
dna of that character is imbued
in the fact of with great power comes
great responsibility the whole purpose
for him becoming spider-man
a big part of that is from the death of
uncle ben and we've never really had
something like that for
tom holland's character so if they were
to kill off anne mae i feel like that'd
be
very bold of them to do absolutely i
don't feel like a death would be
completely finite
i mean it's freaking handmade and you
know she's not even old and me in this
in this franchise to kill her off would
put spider-man in a position where he's
always looking for some type of parental
figure some type of guardian and so it
would
actually sort of do this like uh
slingshot effect to his character really
having to be independent yeah absolutely
i mean these spider-man movies have had
a lot of fun
to them and a lot of sort of
coming-of-age whimsy
but i feel like too if we're going to
cap off a trilogy that could be
they've said you know uh that kevin
feige was interested in taking a sort of
different direction with some of the
backstory of peter in this one and i
mean we've had uncle ben alluded to like
on the suitcase and far from home but it
does feel like
after the loss of tony stark who seems
to have kind of filled some of that
mentor at least with emphasis that
mentor placed in peter's life in the mcu
it seems like that would yeah really
solidify a turning point for the
character of like he loses not only
someone who has you know been there for
him and mentored him but like his last
remaining family i feel like yeah and
especially with their reports like aunt
may isn't the biggest part of the
previous two movies but she is
definitely distinct
and their relationship their chemistry
on screen is something you know that's
quite lovable and so yeah
if they were to take that turn i feel
like that would
kind of solidify the ending of a chapter
and then set up
you know peter's college years peter
turning more into an adult and whatnot
yeah i hadn't expected it but especially
with no real
prominent uncle ben one way or the other
in this iteration
i feel like that could be an interesting
way to spice things up and to also
deliver
something at the end that feels finite
and that leaves us you know with the
sense of loss as well as triumph because
i'm sure there's going to be a lot of
that too
you know well i think the character
death of andrew garfield i don't
feel like would really serve it's more
yeah just so he can say goodbye to it
yeah yeah
uh but i don't know how any of us really
feel
about it all depends on how it would
handle but i'd be kind of bummed
actually if they just brought back
i'd be okay with him like putting a
stamp on it or saying bye but i don't
know how i feel about him
dying in this so i don't know how i'm
bored i am for does that feel absolutely
necessary for him to die
yeah it's unclear who the main central
villain of this movie is
from like a certain plot leak that did
come out and there's been a couple of
conflicting plot leaks that have come
out they both
seem to be headed towards the direction
that goblin will be the main villain in
this one but if it's willem dafoe's
green
goblin if they're doing this plotline of
peter
wanting to kill him and he's on the hunt
for him maybe it's mj
maybe it's zendaya's mj who actually
gets killed off
uh oh interesting it's like kind of
swapping in the glen stacey world cause
then there's mj is
sort of a riff on mary jane not exactly
it's not michelle it's not mary jane
pulled from the comics
you know so maybe that's the case either
way it's kind of a weird thing to
hope for but i do think that it would be
kind of neat if they did actually have
a very impactful death for a character
in the spider-man movies but you know
nothing seems concrete and marvel
everyone seems likely to come back at
some point no one
ever really in
all right guys well someone were to die
in the spider-man 3 film who do you
think it will be who do you think it
should be
leave your thoughts down below who
deserves to die who deserves to die in
the spider-man films all right guys well
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button keep a look out for
more videos tomorrow
got at least three planned uh conjuring
and then uh maybe an early mortal combat
video
it's mortal kombat see you guys